foreign
also from me to
the python python Summit uh I'm here to
evangelize you all to the cult of rust
or uh maybe just talk a little bit about
it uh I'm choking of course like there's
a lot of good reasons to use different
program programming languages as well uh
like Python and but since this is the
last python Summit I can pretty much say
whatever I want
and also
since we're a bit early on time I hope I
get through it
um yeah
so I want to take you on a bit of a
journey
um of my programming life I've been
programming for almost 20 years now and
it's been a fun ride
um I would say especially like the early
years where I didn't program
professionally have been very fun
because I got to do things like the
Monday board and like other
fun things I
um eventually
wrote
a video game it did work it wasn't very
pretty but it wasn't an Eggo shooter
with uh with network capabilities I then
forgot all about Network again and like
I didn't know anymore what TCP was in
UDP and so uh
a bit later I started working at a
company in PHP that's why there's no
slide because I don't want to be proof
that I work on PHP but like
I I mean
at least at least Danilo is working in
the back there knows how horrible it
really was and like
um my code base especially like I think
I had like a thousand lines of reg
Expressions that were then like put
together in some ways and parsing
something uh yeah it wasn't good so but
like
then I I studied and I I I started a
project called Jedi and Jedi Auto
completion uh is something that you're
you might be using or you might be using
pie charm it's pretty much
either of the two or it has been like
nowadays there's also in vs code there's
a kind of a different engine
um I'll talk about that a bit later
um this was like
2012 and I've been doing this pretty
much ever since uh this is kind of an
open source project uh I attended like
three years uh
off like just open source work basically
I've had saved up some money and like it
was just kind of fun to do that and as I
said before I I kind of like doing
things
just because I like programming and so I
just didn't work at that time I then
went to Afghanistan and uh
I'm only telling you this because I
needed some pretty pictures to calm you
down if if there's like
ugly rust stuff coming
and so
um during that time I would say I was
pretty religious when it comes to
languages
um
probably in life in general I was pretty
like strong-minded but when you can't
when it came to languages I thought like
python was the greatest thing that's
ever been invented and nowadays I'm like
and be more open-minded I guess there's
a lot of good languages out there a lot
of good reasons to use one over another
then obviously at some point uh money
started running out and I was able to
get some money for Jedi uh from like
companies but like it wasn't enough at
all
uh so I joined a company called Cloud
scale
um
I'll mention this later a bit uh but in
general
um this was
it's a python jungle Shop with a lot of
react and go uh
or that's what I'm doing not we're not a
Django shop we're an infrastructure as a
service company but I'm like the fifth
best programmer there we're like four
developers
so go figure uh nobody if if you want to
work with us in general just we also
have system engineers and we have some
Network engineers
so feel free to contact me uh we're
always open to talk
[Music]
um
so why did I why rust why did I uh think
about that well for me like
the main idea was to get like Jedi to a
faster place because like if you're
typing in your IDE or your editor you
want to get Auto completions in a really
fast Manner and like in for some
libraries like numpy and others it was
just not fast enough really or it's
still not fast enough in my opinion it's
kind of it works but it's yeah it could
be nicer and like rust is considered in
general to be really fast uh like 10 to
100 times faster in like those micro
benchmarks and I think this holds up
pretty well for like larger programs as
well because in in other languages like
Java where you have like a chit or
or go with the garbage collection like
there's issues that like
stop you from getting that speed up at a
certain scale but in Rust there's not
really like rust is just as fast as C
basically and
but like for the general world the
reason why they use rust is because it's
fast and it's memory safe and for people
who don't know what that means is that
like in in C if you write something you
just have pointers and those like those
pointers can point anywhere and pretty
much uh
if you make a mistake as a programmer
somewhere you will it will lead to
memory box and that leads to
segmentation faults and other nasty
things in general you could also say
Mozilla where that's where rust comes
from
um
try to make this language because they
had issues with in Firefox like a lot of
a lot of the
the security box you see out there are
issues with Android unsafe programming
languages
um yeah
so Russ doesn't have garbage collection
and
how it does that we'll see later
um
so
in general the programming World Lots
rough like you hear it everywhere
um this is also because it has like like
python it has a democratic kind of
community uh a good license uh a
friendly Community
um rust has like a really nice package
manager called cargo
um which is like way better than pip
which is way better than npm
um
so but like
and yeah and then there's these like
surveys and everybody loves rust and
people don't love python as much anymore
I guess but this is mostly hype because
python is still like the primary
language in universities and like rust
is a language that's Barely Used by
anyone in a professional environment
it's mostly like
people on GitHub and like
missionaries
so uh and I I guess like people loved
python before they really used it
um and I think this is a general Trend
like people off go because before they
used it and I kind of thought go was a
good language before I used it I don't
like it
or I think good reasons uh it's probably
a good language for like big Enterprise
uh
companies and like stuff like kubernetes
with an insanely huge code base but not
for like smaller projects which I like
to work or like medium-sized projects
which I like to work on and like even
even like languages like typescript
which to be fair is a pretty good
language and like has has very nice
features
like those languages are also hype
because nobody uses them
or like
like most most companies started using
typescript but like all of the old code
is still JavaScript generally speaking
and then there's stuff like rape crap
which is like a really nice grip
replacement and so people just hype it
up so but like what is rust why why
would he use it the Rust book describes
it as a programming language that helps
you write a faster more a more Reliable
Software and I think this is mostly true
like
um
the rust language
it really liked I I kind of covered the
fast part but like the type system
really
enables you to to write Reliable
Software so
let's let's kind of dive into it
um I want to give you a quick overview
over the language I'm this is going to
be very broad
um there's lots of good tutorials out
there so feel free to check those out
this is just like a small introduction
so as a first example I want to show you
um a function in Rust and python that
kind of looks the same in python as
you'll see there's like the the
annotations I set there if you don't
know those annotations as far as I know
there's going to be a talk about my Pi
later so you'll be
you will understand what what those are
um but in general like it kind of looks
similar I I had a few more examples that
like
that didn't make made it because of time
reasons uh because I didn't have time
like to show those but like there's like
a lot of such small examples you can
show where the languages look very very
similar like there's braces there but
other than that it's like pretty much
the same there's no return in Rust that
something special where you can just
omit the return and like just write your
code a bit more compact which is like
generally a very great concept that you
learn if you ever write code in it but
so and here kind of we get to the
problem like this is this this was the
easy part and now we already get to the
smart Parts because there's no like
there's a very small kind of set of the
languages it's very easy to use
and that's also kind of a you can write
a lot of code with it but most code that
you'll see is not like that kind of easy
um
so one of the great things about rusts
is macros macros are those things where
it looks like kind of like a function
call
um
but it has an exclamation mark so for
now just assume kind of those are
functions but
it's it's a macro it's kind of like like
what you what you have in C but this is
in in Rust you have hygienic macros so
there's a lot of advantages over C and
like it's a really nice Concept in
general
um so some of those macros are like very
simple like to do or unreachable which
is like race not implemented error in
python or the print Ln macro which is
like print in Python and then there's
like fun stuff like debug
um which is
basically it lets you print the current
line with the debug statement so a times
two and there's a plus one which like
it's just
a A plus like it calculates a times two
plus one but it will print eight times
two and then equals four and in Python
like you could also do this you could
you could just do a print there but then
you would just get four as an output and
I think this is kind of nice to debug
rust sometimes uh especially if you
don't use a debugger and you just won't
have a quick output so that's really
cool and there's other macros that are
kind of cool and it just enables you to
like unlike
a language like go for example that is
very verbal verbs you can just like
write those small things and
which macros enables
so
those are like the simple data
structures of rust there's really not
more I would say
um
and that's also kind of an easy part I
would say
um obviously I wouldn't type daytime
exactly like that in a
in a real use case but like it does the
job come on and
so the the more in like a struct is
basically like a c struct it's basically
what you if you if you've ever
programmed C it's what you would do
there it kind of It kind of reminds you
of a data class in Python but it has a
more like
um
it's just it's very small in memory in
Python a data class still has has a lot
of overhead
um then there's an enum uh in in Rust
this is like
I think like one of the most brilliant
Concepts it's not like rust invented
this this is like
very known in other languages as well
like Swift testers as well and like I I
don't know where they stole it but this
is probably from the 90s or 80s
somewhere
um
and
so an enum is basically you know you
know enums in Python maybe so it can
value can be either a num number a
string or a null kind of like a Json
value and so if but in Python you
couldn't attach a value to
the number in Python it's just a number
a string or a null and here it's a
number and then you have like kind of uh
you know this number is a floating Point
number and you get the number out of it
and so this this kind of enum thinking
enables a lot of stuff it like rust has
generics and so like
these are like some of the generics
you'll be using all the time uh it's
option and result option is basically
either a null or or in Python and none
um and in Rust as well
and or as some or something and
um
so
and
this also kind of means because we have
optional result we just return a result
of something and this means that we
don't have error like we don't have try
catch or like like that traditional
object-oriented error handling
um and so maybe hands up who's using
python 3.10 already
that's a that's you that's almost more
than I expected so in Python 3.10
there's a new feature called match and
match is
something that rust also has
um
you'll see below that uh
how the syntax kind of is in in Python
um you might be using it at some point
um in the future if you haven't already
um
in general in Rust uh it's kind of a bit
nicer because
the types like first of all it lets you
unpack enums and as you can see up there
this is kind of the case where we have
first we have a number we want to say
um
so we get that kind of value thing
we say value colon call number and then
we kind of get the number and return it
or and this is like kind of the last
thing this is like a wild card match
that also exists in Python by the way
and or we just return none so we kind of
have our option and then there's like a
third thing there that I do there
um where
I'm like printing a to-do so why is the
string coming here so this will
eventually lead to a trace back and
just like kind of nice to program this
way
um
there's another like pattern matching uh
kind of piece of code that I wanted to
show you that kind of shows why pattern
matching is so nice this kind of thing
also works in Python what what doesn't
work in Python in Python you cannot
return a Val like in Python it's an
expression it's not a state in Python
it's a statement not an expression so in
Rust it's an it's an expression and you
can return values from inside that's why
I didn't like the python proposal very
much though like I don't want to blame
them because like python just works very
different
as a language in very different ways as
a language so that's kind of hard so
what we do here is we just
um
we have a list
of
Rings or values again of those like Json
kind of type values and
so the first example is just oh if it's
empty just print print something then
it's if it's like if the first
value is a string and it's and the
string is hello and the second string is
also is world then we say print hello
world
and then we say if if there's two uh if
there's just any two values
we print we print them both values
that's kind of the syntax in print LM to
like in Python you can in in kind of
format strings as well this is also very
similar or we have it to do for all
other cases and so this is kind of how
pattern matching Works uh
if you don't know that kind of part like
don't worry but you can learn it for
python as well in the future it's pretty
nice
uh so let's cut to the hard parts and
here's here is where we take a deep
breath
and
we kind of look at the more more
annoying Parts in rusts
so the first thing that I wanna
talk about is trade traits don't seem to
be that hard it's basically an interface
for anybody who's worked with like Java
or c-sharp or whatever
um in in Python there's kind of not
really like there are interfaces like
it's abstract base classes but nobody
really uses them so or maybe not nobody
I don't want to offend you but you're
probably the only person in the room
and so
uh in Rust like those look very simple
at first but there's just so many things
that you'll stumble over like Associated
types or generics or like lifetimes with
like invariant variances and there's it
they are just hard
and then one of the other things that
are hard is
creating macros macros uh so if you say
stay like like if you you we write a
macro here say hello and then below we
just executed a macro basically is like
in C uh just
uh
a few commands that will get executed at
or like you can write pretty much
anything there in print Ln hello and it
will get executed where the macro is
like this is good if you don't want to
like deal with inlining and stuff and
you just want to say here execute all
this stuff and you don't have have to
duplicate code but it's still pretty
hard to write them I always have to look
the even though I wrote a lot of those
macros I always have to look up the
syntax like this part is pretty easy but
there's like way more coming not in this
talk but like
so
there's uh lifetimes and ownership is
really hard in Rust I think it's some of
the
hardest
like Concepts to grasp in general like
this piece of code looks very
simple it has references which we
haven't seen before and references
always carry lifetimes usually like rust
is able to figure them out and like the
compiler will say oh yeah this is fine
you can do it but here because you have
two references in the input Russ doesn't
know what the output will be and like
this will result in like this weird
error and you're like oh what what
should I do and but like rust is pretty
cool because uh and don't read the error
but rust will uh tell you oh yeah you
should probably do this and most of the
time it's correct it's just that if your
code gets more complicated rust will not
be able to help you anymore
um
but like error messages in Rust are
pretty good for simple things it's just
that for complicated things they're
horrible and like you'll
want to kill yourself
like sometimes I'm I'm just like four
hours working on like
why a lifetime is not the way it should
be and this is mostly because I work a
lot with lifetimes when I I program rust
but yeah
it is what it is uh the correct example
looks like this where you kind of have
to specify a lifetime uh it's
with an apostrophe
um
and but this kind of starts to look a
bit
unlike python it's kind of annoying
already
um and I mean
but this is really what rust boils down
to this is really what rust is under the
hood uh it always has those lifetimes
it's just that most of the time you
don't really have to specify them if you
only use like one lifetime
um so and then you're like okay I want
to understand rust better I I'll I try
to look at ownership and lifetimes and
how they all interact and you land here
and you're like what like this is this
is just what like in in Python this is
just how you pass a value around like
how you pass a parameter around and but
there's like
uh different kinds of ownership with
threats and allocations and then there's
also libraries that have even different
uh well so we don't even look at this
I just wanna I just wanna I just wanted
to show you how complicated it is and
again
uh now we're going to the insane parts
of rust uh again Afghanistan a deep
breath
um
because it's not gonna get better
um for parts here I
I don't even have code examples because
it's like it's hard to show like the
madness in its full Glory
um in
in general I would say like
and I think this is something that most
trust deaths would say avoid unsafe if I
had time I would let you recite a prayer
uh Thou shalt not use unsafe because
unsafe makes like everything possible
it's pretty much like you can just write
C now you can like use pointers and
whatever
um and this is also part why the
language is so powerful because you can
basically do anything but it's also
really hard
um so
I warned you
um and then there's like certain box and
uh especially like around newer language
features and
like like this piece of code I don't
think anyone understands like in a quick
way how what that is what it is
basically just passing in uh
closure and getting it out again and
avoiding certain bugs and and this is
like but this is like what what rust is
at a very very high level like low level
um
it's just
lifetimes and generics and
and hard to understand and this is just
one of the bugs I created and I think I
have like I've created like one or maybe
two python bugs in like 10 years and it
was more in libraries and not in the
compiler and here because the rust
compiler is so complex and can do so
many things you'll just
um see issues
though I have to say if you use my pie
which is also kind of a compiler for
python there's also like a ton of bugs
and
this kind of issue which is like around
closures and lifetimes enclosures also
means that
um
async is pretty hard because it works a
lot with closures and so
that's that kind of thing another thing
I found was like trade lifetimes that
bounce that are bucked we're not going
to look into this but it's like it just
showed me uh
that's it's it's hard and then there's
like kind of the fun stuff I just wanted
to show you this because it's really
insane that you could do this
um because this executes python inside
of rust and and this is probably not the
best idea there's better way to ways to
interact with python in Rust like
there's really good libraries
just fine tutorials about them
but so this basically what it does is it
has a python interpreter inside of the
macro and
how it does that is kind of complicated
to explain but basically everything
inside a macro is a token stream and you
can execute that in an external process
and so inside of those uh braces you can
do pretty much whatever except that the
syntax like the syntax tokens have to
kind of resemble rough
or have to be rust tokens which is crazy
to be honest and like but since rust and
python share like a lot of the tokens
you can just write python in it
but this is I think it also uses
unstable rust so and I'm definitely not
recommending this I'm just showing it to
you because you can do it so but this
leads me to like
talking about is rust buggier than
python I personally don't think so it's
just for like those like very kind of
crazy features that most people don't
use I've
like one of the organizers here Dennis
works with me he has
he has written some some Rust code
that's pretty easy to understand uh it
doesn't use lifetimes it doesn't use
macros
um it doesn't use trades as far as I
know so he's avoided pretty much all of
what I just showed you so you can write
pretty simple and like very readable
code in Rust it's just if you're a code
base grows to a certain size it's kind
of hard
um
Python and Ross to me feel very stable
um like most languages I've used except
I think when I started writing some
stuff in JavaScript like like eight
years ago like in note it just with SEC
fault but like that's the only time I've
ever had issues with with languages in a
big way
so now I want to talk a bit about
certain case studies and I
it's mostly my experience
this was my alarm clock this is when I
normally get up
[Laughter]
um
so I this is kind of my experience and
why I chose rust and when python in
certain cases and I mean to be honest I
couldn't choose rust like 10 years ago
because it just wasn't really a language
at that time but
now it is and I just want to talk about
when to use which one and no none of
those case studies is gonna cover the
video game I wrote when I was like 18
years old because that one that one is
out of questions so uh
then I also want to mention I'm not kind
of in the Enterprise world at all if you
do enterprise software or anything like
large scale kind of things shift and
suddenly like go and Java become like
kind of good languages because you can
manage the complexity
uh with a lot of deaths in an
organizational way and the code bases
don't uh become like those huge masses
that they can become if you're not
cautious with python and rust
um
so but again let's in let's get into it
as a first case study I want to talk
about
Jedi and my pie in Rust
um this is a kind of and or Jedi in Rust
sorry
um
this is what I wrote like 10 years ago I
have been working on this for a long
time it's probably like
or
four to five men years now of my time
it's it's an open source alternative to
pie charm uh
it's there's plugins for all major
editors and I think vs code has used it
for a long time when they weren't able
to to write their own stuff
um
now they use a different kind of thing
for it but
um it's called pyrite by the way and
that's pretty good
um but I'm rewriting Jedi in Rust now so
that will be better and
it's also used in IPython and Jupiter
notebook so if you if you use that you
I'm pretty sure you're you are using it
and it's kind of pretty big and at the
time when I started it just I just
wanted to get it out as soon as possible
and that's also why python was a great
choice because like python is a great
prototyping languages language you can
just get something done really quick
um
the long tail is different
um there were a lot of issues I was like
after three months I had another
completion libraries and then I spent
like eight years reworking and
refactoring it but it's still kind of
amazing that you can like
through kind of a complex piece of
software in Python and just write that I
don't think that would have been
possible in Rust and if I if it took me
like two years to have a first kind of
user open source user
I don't think I would have done it
um
so in general
python is however a bad fit for Jedi or
anything
that looks like
uh looks like Jedi because like Jedi is
a CPU bound uh process like it it just
has to parse things quick and has to use
type inference and
it's just
it's just a bad fit python is is good
when when it's like I O bound Pro
problems in general so
but it's that's kind of what I want to
say here so if you want to get it out if
you want to ship it early it's kind of
still good but it wasn't good for this
case and that's what gets me into why
I'm re rewriting it I want to rewrite
Jedi and my Pine rust um I'm like
passing like a fifth of the My Pie tests
now and this is
not that much it doesn't look that good
but
um
it will get better and it's really fast
it's like 20 times faster than my pie at
the moment in debug mode and if you use
it in release mode uh I have I have like
a 650 time speed up and
my pie is still kind of optimized so uh
and that's that's like the tests are 650
times faster I don't think like the the
whole thing will be 650 times faster
it's probably more like 10 to 100 but
that's still like good because if you
run my pi over a code base and
it takes you a minute and now it takes
you like five seconds that's like a huge
difference and so that's my hope it's
not finished it's not public but uh do
not unrest it maybe I'll I'll get there
eventually it's been like two years now
and it will take me at least like two or
three more years
and that's like software estimations so
it'll take probably longer
you all know what I'm talking about
and then I
[Music]
study uh of the company I work at
um which is we wrote our control panel
to start servers
um
uh in Python and Django originally and
then we kind of did a refactor and wrote
the the front end in react which is like
our both great choices I think for for
what we're at
um like people sometimes say oh this is
slow and maybe it's Python and like it
always turns out it's not really python
because it's all i o bound it's always
the database it's queries that are slow
and like it's
yeah we're always limited by by our
services because python is not that fast
but it turns out for anything that's i o
bound
um
it's just it's just good and like
latencies could be a bit a bit better
probably without python it would
probably not be like 120 million seconds
for a request but it would be 100 but
who cares really and like if we have to
scale it we just we can just spin up
another server so
that's and that's like the cost of that
is not that big and I'm very much a
proponent of
saving energy but
yeah like spinning up a server is like a
few Watts because I'm not talking about
like a
I'm just talking about a few processes
um so
and like one of the reasons why python
was pretty much a great choice as well
was because initially we had like three
months to rewrite the whole thing in
Python It Was Written in Lua before
which is a very odd choice for for kind
of a bigger project I think
um but and I I would probably choose
Russ now if I was there but that would
probably be a bad idea because I I don't
think I would get it done in three
months in Rust because in Rust like he
just
write all those all that code and then
there's like to Do's in there and
it's yeah it's kind of
it's it's just I don't think it would be
a good choice even though I would
probably choose Ross but that's more
because I'm
like
I think Python's a great language but I
I want to learn new stuff and uh it's
more coming from that angle and not from
oh rough would be a better fit
so yeah
um now I want to summarize the whole
thing
um
I wanna say that
thrust in general is an extremely well
designed
uh language with an extremely
well-designed type system
one of the advantages thrust has over a
lot of other languages is they didn't go
and make a language in like six days
like JavaScript
or uh even other languages that have
been designed like by basically like
python was designed by Guido and like
it's it's very well designed in a lot of
ways but rust had like the advantage
that they iterated over a lot of this
syntax and like core features
um and I think that's great and there's
no garbage collection memory safety and
performance is all great we've talked
about that I think one of the big pluses
for me personally is that when I think
in Rust I think about data structures
when I think in Python I think about
basically algorithms I think in general
like good Engineers should think more
about data structures and less about
algorithms because algorithms are just
like the juice in between and data
structures are
how you should structure your
application and python I think and this
is really what what I was talking about
enums as well kind of makes that hard
and
I've always tried to urge certain core
devs to say to to introduce enums but I
don't think that will happen in the near
future
so uh one of the things that's kind of
neutral for me is that rust is very
strict
um
that's kind of in a type system and it's
very hard to test like smaller stuff
this cannot be
oh this is again the alarm clock
I'm not kidding
um so rust is very strict and it's hard
to test
um
certain things if you just want to say
oh yeah how about this and like in
Python you would just like rewrite it a
bit and like change the data structure
and it might crash in some places but
like you don't mind because you just you
just want to test it and for like that
one Niche case and in the rust it's like
oh you have 200 errors now and before
you fix those you don't get anywhere and
at the same time
you have those 200 errors and you know
exactly where the issues are and in
Python you don't so that's just I guess
an advantage and a disadvantage at times
um I think rough is very hard to read
and learn
um
which is clearly a disadvantage
especially the hard to read part I think
it's it's kind of hard to read even if
you're pretty good at it because there's
so much you can do with it
um lifetimes and ownerships I covered
this
lead to unproductive days I think
there's like at least 10 days where I
haven't done anything except like
debugging lifetimes in the last three
months
and
but I also have to say I do like crazy
lifetime stuff I do like lifetime bounce
with dependencies and stuff so yeah the
mental model
needed for stack and he is pretty crazy
yeah you you just kind of want to keep
kind of this stuff in mind this is a
cheat sheet I don't want to explain it
now but like uh this is what I always
did in the beginning there's
like the other cheat sheet that I showed
you as well here uh though kind of
memorize that stuff and I hope you'll be
fine but it's not easy like it it but at
the same time we're all here to learn
and like if you like software
development uh like more complex stuff
this is really fun
um it's just not
the best business case all the time
but I don't really care about business
cases so
yeah
um so this is I promise this is the last
slide
um
in general pay craft for high
performance CPU memory bound problems
um it's good for when you want to avoid
bugs especially memory box uh and in
general I think you should have a team
of very capable deaths if you don't
I don't think you should be using it
because you'll get nowhere
that's a good thing about rust you'll
just get nowhere it's it won't be
it's just you get you don't you won't
shift software and
um
you basically one of the advantages as
well is you just get one binary
um
and in Python it's just a lot of
dependencies and files that are like
like the python release process is
pretty annoying uh python on the
opposite and is for data science AI uh
is it's an extremely good choice I think
still uh rust doesn't isn't not anywhere
in those areas and I don't think it will
be because most people that use data
science or people that want to like hack
something together quickly and that's
just not what rust is I think and they
don't want to understand a complex
language that's also not why C plus plus
didn't win at all in that kind of
category like high performance Computing
is a different kind of beast but yeah
so for prototypes Python's great if you
have a team of average deaths if you
have like bad deaths it's I don't think
python is a great language because
there's like if you have like a lot of
Juniors and like people that don't
understand the language they'll do
horrible things and they they'll use
meta classes and like weird Global State
and I I think at that point just use
Java and you'll be fine
um and I think like one of the big
advantages of python as well is it's
very hackable and deep debuggable you
can just
at any point like start pdpe or uh
hack something together you can modify
any Global state which is a
very big
danger sign if you've ever if you ever
do it but it's very valuable if you want
to ship something
and with really good in the rough case I
mean like really good type system
experience as well uh not just a very
capable death in another language
so I think this has been my talk uh
are there maybe any questions I don't
know if we do questions we can but uh
and I I want to say one more thing since
this is the last python Summit I want to
say a huge shout out to the people
organizing this uh it's been a blast all
these years it's kind of sad that it
ends but it's also
it's we've had a good run uh I
especially want to thank Danilo who
started this thing I think Dennis and
samueli for organized like for doing the
huge amount of work and yeah maybe
let's clap for them
thank you thank you Dave
um questions
any questions
we have a microphone it's going to get
to you eventually it's right behind you
thank you so uh a few years ago I I
tried to play a little bit with rust
because
all the security people seem to love it
because it's a safe language and you
avoid all those buffer overflows and
stuff like that but I tried to install
it and there was no package for it there
was there was no package in in whatever
distribution I was using at the time I
went to the rest website and
looked for the recommended way of
installing rasps yeah and it's a car
pipe Bash
yes
and I was like those security people
really love this
Jesse I'm not a system engineer I'm an
engineer so that's what system Engineers
say I don't hate that I'm like used to
it now no but you're right like this is
pretty like it's obviously pretty bad
but like I think it's where we are at
the moment because rust is also pretty
new and I think once things stabilize
we'll get better right that was the
question I wanted to ask do you think it
was I hope it will get better but I also
think like it's the same issue like I
we are also in our company kind of in a
process process of
not always using Upstream uh
python of like the operating system and
they are like using Docker instead
because you can just use your versions
because we're on an older system and
we're using python three 3.6 and I would
like to use the newer python features as
well so it's kind of that issue as well
thank you
other questions
oh
um since you did a Jedi in Python and in
Ross now could you sort of give an
indication of the number of lines of
code would it grow massively or stay
more or less the same
um that's interesting actually I think
it's more or less the same it's probably
a bit more in in Rust but also because
of the of the braces that you have so
that just kind of creates a lot of space
but it's not it's not like a Java or
something where you have a lot of kind
of that code that doesn't do anything uh
it's very expressive still but sometimes
the kind of if I would say it's kind of
the same if you do python with
annotations
because in Python if you write
annotations you also use a bit more
space and so it's kind of at that level
I would say thank you
maybe be more but not it's it's not like
I have a question back here and I have
the mic so I can ask it
um here so um you said that you would
recommend python for average deaths and
Ross for experienced developers my
experience is a bit different because if
um if you have a complex code base and
you write rust any compiles you can kind
of trust it if you have a python code
that that you can start it may might
fail in a special way
um so if the Jedi is pretty complex so
if someone does a contribution in python
or in rust from someone that you don't
know which one can you trust more
yeah I mean
I I see the track Comics
um well I mean
I would say in general I don't trust
contributions anyway so it doesn't it
doesn't really matter but like uh I
think you have a point that you can
trust rust contributions but I think I
also have a point that in Rust it's kind
of hard to ship a product with average
or bad devs that have no experience in
Rust because they'll just get nowhere
and in Python I mean it might be buggy
and it might be bad software and like
but at least it will work somewhat and
maybe it crashes from time to time but
people don't care it's software you know
there's one oh yeah
so how easy is to use rust as an
extension from python you showed the
other way around but
it will be more interesting it's
probably pretty easy I haven't used it
personally that's why I didn't show it
uh like what's definitely possible since
rust works great with like interacts
great with C you can just use cffi and
just use kind of the C uh stuff but then
there's also
is it called pi03 or piodite I'm not
sure it's like
there's there's a pretty good way to
interact with it I think but what like
one of the issues is going to be that
like Python's reference counted and rust
has like lifetimes at its core so you'll
have to structure your code kind of in
that manner but you usually you'll just
wrap rust objects and you you write a
small interface so that's very possible
I don't think it's harder than C it's
kind of the same difficulty
this one too
and maybe maybe one more thing uh and I
think that's also kind of a great
application that I where I will see rust
coming in as well uh like like libraries
like numpy or scipy they're all written
in C and like they could just be written
in Rust so I think that's kind of the
way how the languages will interact
together
uh yeah so in recent years I've read a
lot about both Python and the rust kind
of pushing into the
embedded space like I'd say Arduino
class Hardware
um if I don't really know either one of
them for embedded development do you
have like a suggestion with which one to
start or is is there like a clear winner
or
I I would say there's a clear winner
there and that's that's rust and not for
for the reason that I don't like python
there but the issue is that like python
needs a runtime and
you cannot compile Python and so like
python will be running on like
certain boards but not on all boards and
rust will run on pretty much anything
that c runs on It's just sometimes it's
kind of annoying to get to work to get
it to work but like
and then but I mean if you use it like
most of those projects are like for fun
anyway so just use whatever you like
like it doesn't really matter but like
rust is the winner in in the sense of it
will be part of the industry python
really I don't think python will be part
of the industry in that space there's a
lot of power and like
it's just too slow and too memory hungry
okay so actually no question but the
comment to this question how easy it is
to interface with python so I have a
little bit experience this is pi or
three thingy yeah and
um so as you said it's it's very easy in
some cases you even have a macro where
you just can turn
um a rust function directly into a
python function inside the module okay
so that sounds like it's great it's it's
really great in my in my experience
um okay to that then before there was
another question about the security so
I'd say rust is not a secure language it
is a memory safe and thread safe
language but It suffers all the other
risks other programming languages have
as well
but
um with respect to this I I read that
um I think one month ago
the rust Foundation got funding for a
security group so that they're really
addressing this issue now
well I I don't know anything about this
particular case I don't really follow uh
rust the language
in
I I follow the the release notes but I
don't like read that that kind of news
uh I would just say
like when you say rust is not a
a secure language I would I would kind
of counter that with yes it's memory
secure and obviously that's kind of part
of it but it's also more secure than a
lot of other languages because it
doesn't suffer certain problems like
null pointer exceptions or
um
um this is not my alarm clock
yeah I mean but also another point there
is memory so this is oh again five
exceptions I mean like like like uh like
in Python
where it it is memory safe but it will
just fail at a random point and like or
it will kind of inject the weird value
that you
in in Java you can just
push a non like a null somewhere and
it's still memory safe but like it can
lead to weird behaviors and
one more question
thank you
um when you mentioned that rust might be
harder to to test compared to python
um I guess you won't agree but does that
mean that it's less appropriate for a
bigger code bases where you might need
to rely more on unit tests
what what did you like I'm not sure if
like I
I know what you're referring to can you
maybe clarify that like well you
mentioned that it's harder to test I
haven't worked with Russia with like I
don't I don't think it's harder to test
in an automated sense it's it's not it's
not hard like you can write tests and
it's it's great like cardo is great for
testing and everything it's just that uh
if you want to like try something
and like just like change this line of
code and like see what it does that kind
of stuff is like kind of annoying rust
okay yeah got it
okay if I may ask one last question yeah
um then um continue on on that topic
I've heard recently a lot of talk about
um Linux kernel modules being written in
Rust yeah right so it's going towards
like the more larger complex code basis
and you also mentioned like hey like
maybe when you get to Enterprise level
large code bases and so on it can get
complicated to organize code how do you
see that future going well I mean I like
it's I think the kernel is a bit
different than Enterprise level software
because it's kind of different people
doing that kind of stuff and
I think kernel deaths are like usually
like the most capable deaths so they'll
find a way uh in general one thing I
didn't mention is compile times compile
times are like kind of okay I guess in
Rust but they're nowhere near go or
whatever or see
um and so there's good incremental
compilation so you can work with it I as
a def I don't have really I don't have
issues but
um
like I think if you had like a million
line code base and especially if it's
just one crate which is like the a
package
that's where things I think will start
to slow down and you'll have compiled
times of like a minute or even higher
whereas in C or C plus plus it's just
better or like languages like go like go
is a good example in go the compile time
will probably like be 10 times or 20
times faster and that's just
something
it might not be 10 times but like it'll
be faster by a significant margin and
for for deaths that's just very nice one
thing I didn't mention is like what's
what's cool about rust though especially
compared to python tests will run really
quick so I will compile like
especially in relief mode I will I will
run like
a thousand tests in like 0.1 seconds
and
but it will like compile for like five
seconds so it's like as fast as python
at that time at that point but I can I
can run all the time all the tests all
the time which I usually don't do I use
Pi test and then I I run like five tests
or one test and that's it yeah
thank you very much Dave thank you